well hey guys in this video today we are
going to showcase to you something very
peculiar that we saw in pacific rim
uprising that is the different touhou
and most of our saturns that were
confirmed as gaijus in that movie and
there were also other monsters from
other movies as well so let's find out
which ones
they were all seen in a screen depicting
the names and logos of the kaiju that
were in the database of the pan pacific
defense go and although they might not
have been canon and just easter eggs
it's fun to think that these kaiju would
have battled the jaegers too
so let's see which kaijus are on that
list
number one guyron goeron is an alien
monster from the movie gamero vs goeron
that generally walks on all fours but
can stand up on two legs as well with
tough gray skin and a small mouth sleepy
looking eyes and a deep groaning roar it
is an unusual looking monster however
the most unique characteristic is the
massive sword on its head which is
nearly as long as his body it kinda
looks like knifehead in a way
number 2 batra this moth kaiju who
appeared in the 1992 film godzilla vs
mothra battle like mothra has both
larval and imago forms batro's imago
form has a mostly black body and very
huge wings with red black and yellowish
markings he also has yellow horns on his
head six legs red eyes and that light
purple when he fires his beam and a red
line running down the sides of his body
number three zygra zegra is an alien
monster and the main antagonist in
gamera versus zygra the seventh gemera
film zeiger is a deadly opponent who
looks like a cross between a goblin
shark and a bird possessing a silvery
grey armored plated height a pointed
nose a row of sharp dorsal fin on its
back as well as sharp pictorial ones
this guide you actually would look very
much like a trespasser or a knife head
number four glover another monster seen
in the screen is actually not from
touhou but an american monster from the
cloverfield movie this is also a giant
aquatic creature that is massive and one
that we kind of hope in the future would
fight against the jaegers in kind of a
crossover movie or something like that
clover is a quadruple monster that
creates chaos wherever he goes
number 5 dragon if you can't believe it
even jagan was seen in the list this
space kaiju who was one of the arch
enemies of godzilla would have been
quite a problem against jaeger's dragon
spots a circular saw weapon located in
his abdominal region
large steel hooks for hands with smaller
ones for toes spikes running down his
tail three large fin light sails on his
back and a red cybernetic visor for an
eye
number six gummera essentially a giant
superpowered ninja turtle gamera has his
own franchise and was very surprising to
be seen in that list imagine a giant
turtle that can fly at supersonic speeds
shoot flames from its mouth and with a
shell that can withstand any weapon
imaginable i don't think that this kaiju
could be defeated by any jagers well
maybe by a group of them but not a
single one
number seven varan this is a tri-phibian
kaiju that first appeared in a 1958
touhou film of the same name and later
debuted in godzilla franchise in a 1968
film destroy all monsters in his debut
film varen was a huge prehistoric
reptile and is a primarily quad petal
monster with tin membranes between his
arms and legs which he uses for gliding
in a manner akin to that of a flying
squirrel or sugar glider something like
that
number eight jagger this is an ancient
kaiju an ancient demonic creature from
the continent called moo who first
appeared in a 1970 film gamera vs jaiga
jeiger is
a horned quad appeal reptile somewhat
reminiscent of an extinct dinosaur
triceratops
she has multiple spikes on her face and
a raised fin on her back her skin is
light brown and covered in circular
patterns
number nine yangari this is an ancient
reptile kaiju created by kyondong
entertainment who first appeared in the
1967 tokusatsu film called yangari of
the same name the monster from the deep
yeongar is a bipedal reptile with a long
horn on his snout tossed on the size of
his mouth and a single row of dorsal
blades similar to godzilla but shorter
he has red glowing eyes and spice on his
tail like a stegosaurus
number 10 baragon baragon is a
subterranean reptile kaiju who was first
seen in the touhou film frankenstein vs
paragon and later debuted in godzilla
destroy all monsters it is a quadripedal
mammal reptilian creature with
reddish-brown skin a single large horn
on his forehead
somewhat like knife head again which is
followed by several backwardly curved
spikes on the back of his head and large
floppy ears
number 11 gaias
this is another kaiju from the gemara
franchise and it is a flying kaiju
similar to rodan imagine this the pan
pacific defense go having to fight
another flying kaiju like otachi that's
going to be something this was the arch
enemy of gemara and was a very powerful
creature gaius resembles a giant
pterosaur or a bat like creature with a
flattened arrow-shaped head leathery
wings with three claws on each
and lastly number 12 the muto and
finally a monster from the most of us
the muter was seen at the bottom of the
list of the kaijus on the screen most of
us know about this six-legged parasitic
kaiju with a power similar to that of
leatherback that can emit emp that can
kill any electronic equipment in a wide
radius think about the jagers fighting
both the female and the male mutos
and maybe even the muted prime that'll
be the day
and so with that we come to the end of
the video on the touhou and most of us
kaiju seen in pacific rim uprising well
not as much scene as just depicted on a
screen but anyway that's still quite an
idea to make a spider-man no way home
kind of a scenario but with monsters in
a monster multiverse so subscribe to be
a part of the minecube family and hit
that like button and we'll see you in
the next one take care fam